This is our old code, I want to demonstrate the vulnerability
in our old code so we can make sure we fixed
it. This is the old code running here and if we
were to take a look at this. We're going to modify our
cookie. Document.cookie. That is the value. Let's say we want to set this to
visits to 10,001. First we need to find what the hash of 10,001. We can use
python for that. let's go ahead and try that real quick. Import hasLib,
hashLib.md5.("10001").hexdigest,
'kay. We'll take this value here. Let's
take that with us into our browser. We're
forging cookies here. So we're going to say documents.cookie
equals Visits equals 10,001 pipe our new
hash value, now when we reload this page, we are the best ever. But we're
not the best ever, we just cheated. Okay,
so, let's incorporate the new functions we just
wrote into our code. So here we are in
our editor, and I've plopped in our new function. We're
going to, move secret out of the way. We are going
to pretend it is actually in another module that you
don't publish or share. And now our functions should be
as good as new. Let's try this, let's try this
out in our browser. So here we are in our
browser, we have dropped in a new hashing function so
our old cookies are going to become invalid and when we
reload the page you can see we've been here one time.
If we were to inspect the cookie, document.cookie, we see that
we have this cookie. Now, it's got the same format at
the previous cookie, except this one is very hard to forge.
Without knowing that secret, we, all we can do is guess
at the hash. And that's. You know, the property of the
hashing algorithms is that that is basically impossible to get correct.
So if I were to modify this cookie, document the
cookie equals visits equals 10001. I mean what value do we
even put in here. I mean we can iterate over,
you know, every possible hash and just kind of guess at
it and maybe get lucky. But we'd have to get
extraordinarily lucky. You see, I reloaded the page and reset down
to one. When I mean extraordinarily lucky, I mean we'd have
to you know, take more time than there are you know,
atoms in the universe to figure it out. So, that's
not going to work in our favor. Okay, so that's pretty
cool. I just want to summarize that algorithm so, so it's
clear what we did. Instead of setting the cookie visits
equal 1, which can be easily forged And instead of setting the cookie visits
equals 1, and then the md5 of 1, which can also be,
also be easily forged if you know that we're using md5. We instead set
it to visits equals 1 pipe HMAC, Secret comma 1. And
as long as we keep this secret secret, they can know our
algorithm, they can know what we're doing, they can even see
our code and they won't be able to forge invalid cookies, which
is a pretty neat property. We use this all the time
because imagine, if we're not counting,
instead of counting visits, we're counting
user IDs. It would be a real big problem, you know?
If, if I'm logged into, you know, my mail, my Gmail, and
I've got a cookie that identifies, you know, who I am, if somebody
could just say, well, you know, my user ID is Steve's user ID,
and then, if he logged into my email, that would be a very
big problem. So, that's why you do things like this. This prevents people from
forging your cookie. And also, it saves you some effort validating on the
server side, because if, if this doesn't validate, you don't have to check to
see if the string is all digits and that sort of stuff because
you know, it came from you, you know what you set it to, and
that makes your life a little simpler. So this is a really
popular strategy we're going to use for all sorts of things in this class.